c'était notre métier on était des
vignerons en algérie depuis y aura à peu
près 120 ans et on est retourné en
france éventuellement on est venu au
canada dans les années 60 on s'est
retrouvés ici à niagara et mon père il a
établi château des charmes en 1978 quand
mon père a commencé moi je tiens de ce
premier un foyer alors moi j'ai appris
ce métier en commençant à creuser des
trous et planter des vignes et frappé
les poteaux dans la terre le château des
femmes est l'un des premiers vignobles
au canada à cultiver 17h européen le
chardonnay le riesling pinot noir
cabernet sauvignon merlot mon père yves
c'est ça qu'est ce qu'ils connaissaient
après il était convaincu qu' on ne
pouvait établir ces cépages ici au
canada en plus des vignes la famille
bosque importe aussi le concept du
domaine qui lui donne un air contrôle de
la qualité de son produit en france le
domaine et changent pas juste
producteurs de vin soit aussi éleveur de
réserve une quinzaine d'années plus tard
le duo paris fils fait construire cet
édifice emblématique du vignoble une
nouvelle destination touristique ouverte
au grand public
on avait vraiment pas de concurrent dans
les années 80 90 mais il ya des grosses
compagnies ou des ou des entrepreneurs
avec beaucoup plus d'argent que la
famille bros qui l'ont construit des
établissements des châteaux et même mais
ça c'est une bonne chose je ne me plains
pas de ça parce que
cette diversité c'est ça qui permet
quelque chose comme 2 millions de
touristes par an qui vient de voir blake
avait les vignobles de niagara des
vedettes des politiciens même la reine
d'angleterre déguste les vins du château
des charmes
j'ai eu l'opportunité de faire la
connaissance de la de la reine en
angleterre avec mes vins oui ça c'était
ça c'était une journée exceptionnelle
les être vigneron c'est être constamment
à la merci de dame nature et en 2020
l'apport des me frappe
les ventes de vins s'effondre ce qui
s'est passé la dernière année et l'umih
avec au vide
c'est énormément difficile parce qu on
était très très exposé au tourisme on a
perdu le marché pour la restauration
parce que tous les restaurants étaient
fermés
le retour des visiteurs canadiens est
donc bien accueilli une lueur d'espoir
pour l'industrie qui bat de l aile
l'entrepreneur envisage les prochains
mois à décrypter misme mais sans se
faire d'illusion je ne suis jamais
croire que le loup est plus à la porte
c'est pas un métier facile pour une
entreprise à ses petits avec moins de
sentein poids hier ça peut ça peut être
énormément compliqué
[Musique]